since july 26 2018
we've taken you on a journey of epic
explorations uploading over 500 videos
surpassing half a billion views and
finally
reaching 5 million subscribers
now we want to take you on another
journey
except this one's a bit different
we wanted to explore the years since
we've started
to where we are now
our first venture into hypothetical
scenarios
began when we changed the entire world
into vegans this is what if and here's
what would happen if
everyone in the world became vegan
please
change it i can't stand the sound of my
voice from back then
just a couple of months later we made
you fall into a black hole
and since then we've made a habit of
tossing you into whatever you can think
of
pools full of sharks snakes heck even
stomach acid yeah
things can get pretty crazy around here
like the time we took away the world's
oxygen for just five seconds spoiler
alert everybody dies
yeah i know i know you've heard that a
lot on this channel but let's face it
we love killing you in these scenarios
and you
love dying hypothetically of course
okay that's kind of dark let me lighten
the mood a bit
hey on april 16 2019
we uploaded our most popular video on
youtube
what if we dumped our trash into
volcanoes
it's been viewed over 15 million times
shortly after that you brought us to 1
million subscribers
and we showed you a hypothetical world
in which there was a
zombie apocalypse
[Music]
then we got kind of weird
[Music]
we put saturn rings around earth we
showed you
what it would be like if one million
people actually
stormed area 51 good thing that didn't
happen
and we had you swallowed up by a whale
this pushed us to two million what-ifers
and who could forget about all the gross
out ideas that
got us to that point like when we told
you
what it would be like to eat mold or
not to shower for an entire month
gross and throughout our journey
to three million subscribers we showed
you even more new worlds
like one without mosquitoes one where
the megalodon still existed today
and even a donut earth
doughnuts then
we revealed my face in fact all our
faces
and since then our team has been able to
grow
even bigger all thanks to you
and these new faces were able to show
you some hypothetical and
real creatures that you've never seen
before
like what if the kraken was real
showing you what would happen if the
mosasaurus still roamed our oceans today
and bringing you all the way back to the
devonian period
but throughout all this fun escapism we
still did our best to explain to you
what's going on in the real world
[Music]
then on july 7th 2020
you helped us reach 4 million
subscribers
and for the past nine months we've told
you stories from the depths of the earth
to the outreaches of space and
other times we've brought pieces of
space
to us we've even gone back to
some of our earliest videos to show you
just
how much we've learned since then
throw in a fart joke or two tell you
what happens if you
eat something crazy add a podcast and
that takes us to 5 million subscribers
now
this is just a short history of our
journey on youtube and
we hope you stick around to see where we
go next we have some really cool stuff
in the works and we wouldn't be able to
make
any of these videos if it weren't for
you watching and sharing and
suggesting all your ideas so from the
entire what if team
thanks for 5 million subscribers
and as a way to celebrate this milestone
we've just released
a special 5 million subscriber sticker
you can check them out on our website
and
every purchase of this sticker will help
us make better videos going forward
so now that we've reached 5 million
subscribers
5 million subscribers i wonder what
we'll do for 10 million
well we'll leave that story for another
what if